hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 2014
world blitz chess championship
so this is the game between magnus
carlson and judah polgar
i was drawn to this game because of
their recent friendly game
the one they played towards the very end
of the 2022
uh candidates tournament i want to see
when their last serious game was and it
was at this blitz
championship in 2014 carlson was
completely on fire
winning the blitz championship with 17
out of 21
rapid championship
classical championship and setting his
highest ever classical rating at 28.82
so
really cruising along in 2014.
okay in this game we have a king's
indian defense this last move denotes
now
the zamish variation and the first point
to speak of is right about here
in the game polgar follows with c6
additional prep work for b5 but
do know that if you're playing on the
black side in this position and you're
of the gambity type
you could play b5 right away
this has
a benko gambit flavor to it for sure
do know that in giving up
the b-pawn you're not only as black
getting these files to work with but
you have influenced the pawn trio
there's no longer a c pawn around
there's no longer as much control over
that d5 square
and nearby for black there will be e5
and
maybe even d5
blasting up in the center
okay
from here
we have in the game it's c6
black wants to get in this b5 move and
not give up a pawn
white cuts that out
not without its weakness
b4 is now whole b3 is a hole as well
what follows is a5
so this is
clamping down on b4 and vacating a6
notice
notice this idea to expand with b5
this a6 and c6 move
they're played while the queen knight is
still home
and the reason for that
is so that if b5 is stopped like it is
with a4
well now this knight has at least a fast
track into this gap
okay
knight g3
computer already points out that white
could be
super ambitious with g4 and h4 but okay
those are super committal moves
carlson plays much more solid
the g pawn stays home and
we're just looking to develop here
from here knight a6
bishop to e2 there's two options
e2 is the better
uh better square you're out of reach of
the knight
the queen has direct view of d4 this is
a sensitive square
it's not only b4 but d4
this is a hole
also later on we'll see that this knight
wants to make use of this d3 square
in a
very roundabout way
all right
queen c7 now there are a couple lines i
want to highlight right around here
i know it's just a blitz game this was a
3-2 time control
um
but
i took a few things away from this game
and
uh there's a couple poison i'll call
them poison pawn variations to be
mindful of here
if you're playing on the black side you
could even look to
play this next move you could set up
some traps
for your opponent so i'd like to
highlight these
in the game queen c7 is in there
prep work for e5
but e5 can be played straight away it is
considered best
to simply keep the queen home
and what is this first of two poison
pawn variations i'm gonna share with you
well
here we go
if e5 and we have the captures on e5
in a queen exchange
in an excited player who wants to land a
fork
this is not good for white
and here's why
this guy on a5
after knight d7
is stuck
no safe square form
and nearby there's b6 winning the bishop
how do you save the bishop
you have to move the knight so that
there's some new squares
but now look at these knights
ready to pounce
this guy jumps here
this guy jumps here and that's as far as
i'm taking it how bad a position is this
for white it's losing
it's a minus two
these guys here
how to describe them they have an iron
grip over the entire queen side
and this extra pawn that white has
is only temporary
you could very easily see that drop off
a move or two from now
that's poison pond variation
one
and the second one
is this one here
let's say after e5 we don't have this
capture but instead d5
knight d7 can follow now that there is
no longer this control over c5
black is looking to on the next move get
to these squares
or at least get this next move in
knight d to c5
white might bite here though
capture on c6 this is poison pawn
variation number two
not a good line for white here
may be tempting but it's bad
because now knight b4 follows
defense of the pawn
with aggression
ready to land a fork considered best as
queen side castles and now these next
couple moves we're looking to simply
uh
extract the queen from our side of the
board
bishop f8 is nearby
here we go queen only has one square she
has to go back to where she came from
and now black gets out of this pin
and this isn't any problem the queen
falls here let's say h5 look at these
knights
ready to pounce
game over
with knight b3 why could get out of that
but look at this position
where does the queen go she's gotta go
to e1
um
all of these squares i have highlighted
are controlled by the minor pieces the
minor pieces black's minor pieces
are the masters of this position
this is absolutely devastating
um
compare the knights in this position
both black knights are in white's house
and these two clowns are boxed out by
two black pawns no good forward moves
if you have this position on a flash
card and quickly
threw it up in front of an experienced
player's eyes
i think this is the first thing they
would say these knights are monsters
okay that's the first thing that really
sticks out
in you know just at a quick glance
okay
that's poison pawn variation two of two
in the game
we have queen c7
castles e5 only now
d5
h5
and queen d2
that's considered a second best move is
queen to d2
um
now let me play some more moves on see
how this one follows
we have this
typical
chasing away this this idea
h5h4 it's
super common knights that are positioned
on knights3
the rook pawns get excited about
attacking a knight that's on one of
these four highlighted squares
we have h4
only one reply
knight h5
knight's back in the ball game
f5 is looking to next squash the bishop
just in time this knight gets to a nice
square
and the bishop has a new square on f2 f4
bishop f2 and the knight dives right in
to g3 not much thought goes into a move
like this
experienced players quickly understand
sure
you could capture the knight with my
pawn but this guy right here
is not worth just a single point
it's more like three or more
uh especially with the queen still on
board
so
you know this
this capture was not played in the game
if if you try to win material like this
is white you're gonna get killed
nearby there's bishop f6 clearance
for a quick queen h7 queen h2 game over
now this looks pretty dangerous i must
say a night this
uh
deep in white's house
and it seems like you just can't get rid
of it
um
if you want to try and prevent this
situation as white
let me go back to this moment right here
there is a
a preemptive move you can make here
after this h5 move instead of queen to
d2 this is this was a one of the
the learn
something i learned from this game
this variation right here after h5 you
could
play knight h1
before it's given a kick
and the idea here is that if now h4
this is a very time sensitive variation
after h4 there's now queen e1
and this pressure on the h4 pawn
while the knight is on f6 it doesn't
permit black to easily defend h4
for example there is no queen e7
to defend h4 here and how do
you defend h4 in this case
black wants to get this move in next but
again it's time sensitive you don't
can't get that in so easily
what do you do as black if this is the
position h3
well as white you're not going to
capture instead you're going to cut out
the knights pivot square in h5 so there
is no getting into f4
and
soon this knight
will round up
this pawn
looks a little
interesting this knight is running
around in circles but running around in
circles with the point a pawn has just
been one
okay just some food for thought here
keep in mind knight h1
and don't don't allow h4 to hit as hard
paves the way for this idea
okay
in the game it was queen d2 we have this
knight dropping into g3
white reacts with rook d1
and now we have
c5
that
is a big move
and when i saw that move
you know when i was preparing for this
video i thought to myself a little bit
more
uh well i had a closer look let's say
about the
the queen side structures
um
which queen side structure is better i'm
not sure i have a definitive answer to
that one
um but i'll just make some a couple of a
few observations here
um
i'll say it like this
the
white structure
has
holds a key
to
opening
the position
at some point there can be this capture
lines are opened up maybe d6 falls
or maybe even c5 and similarly there's
more pawn tension more pawn captures
will occur it's going to open up
black 2 holds a key
to opening the position
it's probably not such a wise choice to
do this but still
black has the option to open the
position by capturing on d5
and maybe there's a nice follow-up along
the c file
um
in addition to black in addition to
holding a key to opening up the queen
side
black has the only key that will lock
the queen side because of how the pawns
are positioned here
and i just want to draw some attention
to this because there's there's value in
that
this next move is
c5
move 18 and this
means that
there will be no successful pawn breaks
for either side
no b4 no b5 and the action will quickly
have to
shift towards the king side of the board
that's where it still is fluid
you could still see some pawn captures
one way or the other or upon push
engaging with the pawn on g2
so it's a big moment for sure a big
decision
is this one right here
polgar playing c5 and a critical moment
now for carlson
to move 19 i'll throw it to you as a pop
quiz
what move did carlson play next he found
the best move
can you find it
feel free to pause the video
okay
the move in the game is
pawn takes knight
if
you're looking at this newly weakened
square b5 i think that's a
that would be a move that would come to
the mind of many newly weak and square
this knight can move forward generate a
threat
but
this is in fact helping this queen to go
to a more productive square
back home
she's actually doing a pretty good job
on that home square we'll see
why exactly that is the case in just a
little bit
what is
the move played in the game it is h
takes g
h takes g
bishop takes gives the material right
back
and now
looks to hunt this pawn
you could do it in two ways
well you could attack the pawn in two
ways but
only one works
if you go to e1
you would lose
because bishop h6
and after queen takes pawn bishop e3
white is losing this bishop in just two
two tempi
has become an absolute monster
unopposed bishop is now
off the charts active
queen g5 is the follow-up in this game
not only
an aggressive move looking to track down
the pawn but defensive
we're not allowing
the bishop to slither into our position
so easily
this variation is not possible
if you first flick in
this knight b5 move with the queen on
this square if you go for this variation
now
whoa can't go here so we're seeing now a
point
a reason why the queen is a little
better placed on
d8 rather than c7
so the moment to go for this sequence is
right now
with queen to g5
uh what follows next is queen f7
something that crossed my mind
after this
uh sequence occurred
the the captures on g3 i thought to
myself why wasn't that night
why didn't white go for that sequence a
little bit earlier at the first
available opportunity
so i i had to look back here
as soon as the night dropped in like
doesn't this kind of turn out to be
waste why even why even make that rook
move
um
there's a big reason
why you can't go in for this capture
right now so let me highlight this
uh if you go ahead and take
take again
and then play here
while this pawn is still on c6
not c5
you're gonna get hurt
queen b6 this diagonal is still open
ouch
considered best as knight f2
you know that's uh yeah
you're asking
you're going to lose if you have to play
knight to f2 and if you go king to h1
and this would be a fun move to
to to play in a game
king f7 absolute best move
that is going to hurt soon white's going
to have to give the queen with
a variation like this so
game over
for team white
so it is only after c5
c5 that this sequence right here
is available
okay
from this point queen f7
you could take the pawn straight away
but instead
knight b5 both of these moves are
are right around the same
in the computer's eyes so
some pressure on d6
queen f6
queen exchange is avoided we have to
track down this pawn
uh even if the if the queens are off as
long as there's still major pieces this
is
a persistent
thorn in white side
i always have to worry about back rank
mates maybe even stacking the rooks and
getting to h1 is there
okay queen takes g3
bishop h6
there's only one move here a best move
for white
how do you stop bishop e3
king f2
you're opposite these two
major pieces but
can't take advan black can't take
advantage of that
white is stopping bishop to e3
from here knight b4 that's a losing move
right around this stage in the game
there are multiple blunders by
a couple blenders by pulgar and one by
carlson
uh considered best is to immediately
uh look to get to the the rook to the h
file
it's a
a time sensitive
uh position for black
we'll see what an issue is with knight
to b4
after rook h1
in the game we have king g7
in the game queen h4 is played
not the best move this is where carlson
blunders
we have back-to-back back-to-back
blunders here
uh considered best is rook takes bishop
king takes rook
and we have the major pieces entering
black's house a variation like this the
queen is
wicked active
d6 ready to fall
position is so good for white you could
even
exchange queens and you're still
crushing in this position after the
smoke clears where'd we stand
a knight in two pawns versus the rook
super active rook super night
completely winning for white with this
variation but
this was not played instead it was queen
h4 offering a queen exchange
uh polgar is uh welcoming the queen
exchange we do have queen takes queen
here and from this point on it's winning
for white
there's really no chance for black
considered best the only way to stay in
the game
is to decline the queen exchange
g5
defending the bishop in the process
looks a little odd to do this
masking the bishop but this is a
temporary post by the pawn
black needs to keep the queens on in
short
in order to
try and do something along the dark
squares
so this is the last move i'm going to
put on with this variation
this is the idea to try and sneak in and
be disruptive in this way
without the queens on there's really no
great way for
this bishop to be effective
and black will simply be on
the defensive and there's no
what it's going to come down to is that
there's no convenient defender of this
d6 pawn i think the queen is maybe
uh the most efficient defender in this
uh situation
of the of the d6 pawn but
as played we do have a queen exchange
the rook falls back not just to any
square
white keeps open h1 to form a battery
and now there's two issues for
for black to solve and you can't solve
them both
there's still the problem on d6
as well as
the rook threatening to enter on the
seventh rank
black parries one of those threats
goes for this sequence sacrificing the
bishop
giving up essentially
uh
a minor piece or really two minor pieces
just to get rid of the the second rook
so you can't get to the seventh rank but
at the end of this this guy is stuck in
the corner
and the king on c3 completely controls
the knight
and now black has to go on the defensive
with rook a6 not a fun
move at all
to
defend d6 like this
um
after this the knight is going to get
hunted
that's what how it falls in the game
if black tries something else with let's
say rook h8 so that white can't
hunt the knight
that's not really going to save black
because we could exchange rooks
and say to ourself i don't even need to
take time out
to capture the knight i'll keep my king
here your knights under control
and i'm going to knock out this pawn
and use my knights bishops and two
passers
and we don't even need our king
i'll keep our king right there on c3
okay in the game it is rook a6
the knight is picked up
bishop takes knight it's winning in
uh
every which way here
which
capture would you play here are you
going to follow the general rule
taking towards the center or are you
going to be a rule breaker
feel free to pause the video what would
you play here
okay again both are winning but
move played in the game
c takes b5
broke the rule
for what reason
vacates c4
for a knight
a knight on c4
well what is it not going to hit
okay
rook a8
b3 we now have a path in there
rook h8
b6 keeping these guys disconnected
rook h2 rook g1
rook a6
and knight to b2 if black tries
something else other than hunting this
pawn
let's say coming over here
many many approaches i like this one
just cut out the one idea to maybe
exchange rooks
and that'll buy you some time to improve
your king
maybe the king alone could hunt down the
apon the knight could always return
the knight can always return back
in a few moves to put additional
pressure on these points
okay many ways to do it
let's try it is rook a6 in the game
knight b2 rook takes
and one last move
bishop b5
and polgar resigns this rook is cooked
pawn bishop pawn
control this guy no safe squares and
nearby rook
excuse me knight c4 and the rook will
fall
and white's going to be playing up a
minor piece and
an extra pawn or two
no hope here for team black so
some interesting lines in this one again
those
two poison pawn lines on the queen side
the one grabbing the a5 pawn another
grabbing the d6 pawn
and this idea after h5 to make the
preemptive knight h1 move meeting next
h4 with queen e1 very time sensitive
line there but
some instructional
points here from this
blitz game
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you